- Ce n'est pas tous les matins
que les enfants du premier
ministre vont à l'école avec
leur père et des caméramans.
Des milliers d'hommes et
de femmes, de tous les partis,
ne verront pas beaucoup
leur famille au cours
des 40 prochains jours.
- Les Canadiens se rendront aux
urnes le 21 octobre prochain.
- Le chef libéral a
tout de suite donné
le ton de sa campagne.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef
Parti libéral du Canada
- Nos visions pour le pays
sont très différentes entre
l'approche libérale, qui
est positive et inclusive,
et l'approche conservatrice,
qui veut prôner les coupures
et l'austérité
- Cette vision inclusive
se heurte à la nouvelle loi
québécoise sur la laïcité,
qui interdit le port de signes
religieux dans la fonction
publique et les écoles.
- Je ne trouve pas que,
dans une société libre, on doit
légitimiser ou permettre la
discrimination contre quiconque.
- Mais Justin Trudeau dit ne pas
avoir l'intention de contester
la loi, pour l'instant.
Le premier ministre du Québec
lance un appel aux chefs
fédéraux.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
- Ce que je leur demande,
c'est de s'engager, pas juste
pour l'instant, pour de bon,
à ne jamais contester la loi
qui interdit les signes
religieux pour les personnes
qui sont en autorité.
ANDREW SCHEER, chef
Parti conservateur du Canada
- Le compte à rebours pour
que le Canada se débarrasse
du gouvernement de Justin
Trudeau est officiellement
lancé!
- Le leader conservateur attaque
l'intégrité du chef libéral,
blâmé deux fois par le
commissaire à l'éthique
dans l'affaire SNC, notamment.
Le Globe and Mail en rajoute
ce matin en dévoilant que
le gouvernement Trudeau
bloquerait l'enquête de
la GRC sur cette affaire.
- Il doit mettre fin
immédiatement à ses tentatives
de bloquer une enquête
policière.
- Dans plusieurs
circonscriptions, au Québec,
comme ici, à Trois-Rivières,
les conservateurs pourraient
l'emporter si le Bloc québécois
ne performe pas.
- C'est pas le Bloc qui va
remplacer Justin Trudeau, c'est
pas le Bloc qui va laisser
plus d'argent dans vos poches.
- C'est pas un hasard,
dans la dernière semaine,
bizarrement, nous sommes
devenus la principale cible
des conservateurs.
- Bien oui!
- Le chef du Bloc québécois a
lancé sa campagne dans la région
de Québec où il pourrait
reprendre certains comtés.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET, chef
Bloc québécois
- Demandons-nous si, justement,
il ne faut pas relancer avec
vigueur cette idée de faire
du Québec un pays.
- Le chef bloquiste accuse
Justin Trudeau de nuire
aux intérêts du Québec.
Jagmeet Singh, lui, accuse
les libéraux de vendre leur âme
aux lobbys des pétrolières
et des grandes entreprises.
Il promet d'annuler
le contrat des armes vendues
à l'Arabie saoudite.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Entre les priorités
de la population et les grandes
compagnies, les conservateurs
et les libéraux toujours
choisissent les priorités
des grandes compagnies.
- Pour la chef du Parti vert,
c'est l'élection la plus
importante de l'histoire du pays
en raison de l'urgence
climatique. "On ne veut
pas faire peur, dit-elle,
mais donner de l'espoir."
"Nous allons créer des millions
d'emplois, dit-elle,
en convertissant le pays
aux énergies renouvelables
d'ici 2030." Maxime Bernier
promet, lui, de réduire
l'immigration de 60 %.
MAXIME BERNIER, chef
Parti populaire du Canada
- 49 % des gens qui veulent
moins d'immigrants au Canada,
seulement 6 % qui en veulent
plus.
- Tous les chefs,
sauf le bloquiste, seront
dans la région de Toronto
en début de campagne où le vote
des nouveaux arrivants
pourrait être décisif.
Ici Sophie Langlois, Radio-Canada, Montréal.